hello everyone this is Peter Bauer again
and welcome to Pete's lab for another
one of our short lectures vignettes on
subjects related to brownfields and
groundwater this particular
demonstration is a simple demonstration
but it does take several weeks to follow
it along and see everything that needs
to be seen but again it's basic sort of
overarching subject material is just
particles particles in the environment
then I have here in this beaker a pile
of particles you might call it a dirt
sediment I can see some little granules
in there certainly a lot of sand and
then I see some much much finer material
so it's a collection of very small
gravel and then sand and mud now in this
four liter beaker i have approximately
two liters of water and all i'm going to
do is to dump the sediment here into the
water and then stir it and talk as we're
doing it so let's just get started by
dumping oh look at that you can see some
some of the particles in fact are very
small I sister this like this you can
see I don't know whether you can or not
but there is you can see some dust we
might call it particles that have enough
energy in the just by the air currents
to move out of the beaker and into the
environment so those are very fine
particles indeed and let's see if or we
can see a lot more of those very fine
particles well we can see already that
the
water has become dirty or muddy and I
have my trusty spoon here and I'm
beginning to stir the particles but
what's important here and we'll show you
some close-ups of this in a second is to
carefully note how I'm going to stir
this and right now I'm just moving the
particles or go around making sure that
the particles disaggregate that as any
that is any clumps of particles have
fallen apart and all the particles are
loose and independent and I'm just going
to say that that's been achieved okay so
the basic part of this experiment is
started by stirring the sediment in this
water very very rapidly adding a lot of
energy to this system to make sure that
all the particles are off the bottom and
up into the water in suspension before I
stop stirring because what I'm going to
do is then stop stirring and then you
can imagine what's going to happen the
particles are going to be going to begin
to settle to the bottom question is
which ones will settle first if any and
how long will it take I'm also going to
stir this in a circular fashion very
rapidly and I will create a vortex a
spinning vortex kind of like a the
inside of a tornado in here that also
will play a role in what we see later on
so here we go I am now stirring
hey we're going to unite vortex for me I
can still feel that they're consistent I
mean at the bottom there's and
resistance but as I through this faster
and faster that resistance is
disappearing and now I think all the
particles are off the bottom and we can
stop stirring we just simply watch as
the water spins and spins and spins and
begins to slow down on the top we now
have a phone that has developed well the
water hits it's still slowly slowly
rotating but it's nearly come to a stop
some of the phone has now cleared to the
edges there is a little chunk of foam
that's still in the center that's
floating around and what else do we see
here well number one we can see that
there are a number of particles that are
floating which indicates that these
particles are likely to be less dense
than water and perhaps pieces of organic
matter pieces of wood or leave for
something like that that is floating
that would be consistent with the foam
what is causing the phone to develop
well this is pretty much like your
bathtub soaps and the bubble baths that
you have at home here you have a organic
material that will float on the surface
of the water and when you agitate the
water you stir in air into these little
films of organic matter and you create
bubbles so in the same way there must be
some organic materials in the
sediment and some of these organic
materials dissolve in the water creating
a film at the surface and when I
agitated the water the way I did I was
able to entrain air create some bubbles
which accumulated at the top they seem
to be disappearing we also can see some
pieces of sediment that have been left
on the side of the beaker this showing
us the height of our little water
tornado when we were stirring so a lot
of little pieces of evidence are in the
beaker to be seen and observed and
that's going to be one of the tasks over
the next month is to carefully watch and
monitor this beaker to see what happens
see how long it takes for particles to
finally settle to the bottom even now
several minutes after we stop staring we
can see a lighter zone here that has
begun to develop as the particles the
larger particles have begun to settle to
the bottom and we can see a lighter
colored zone that's slowly developing
and expanding but it too is still dirty
so there are particles in there as well
and the question will be how long before
all the particles settle to the bottom
or will in fact all the particles
actually settle to the bottom this image
was taken a few days after stirring was
stopped the water level is at about
2,000 150 milliliters the foam at the
top has dissipated though you can still
see some at the edges the top inch of
the water column shows less sediment in
suspension than the water deeper down
fine sediment is still slowly settling
at the bottom distinct layers can be
seen a lighter base sandy layer with
small granules is at the bottom a finer
darker brown silty layer is in the
middle
in a very thin if you look closely a
lighter layer of clay has formed at the
top of the sediment the total volume of
the sediment is just over 500
milliliters we can apply ste nose loss
of laws of superposition and understand
that the sandy layer is the oldest being
at the bottom was successively younger
layers above it the gravelly sand and
then the silt were deposited very
quickly within minutes after stirring
was stopped the clay layer has taken a
few days to form and is still forming
this image was taken a few more days
later the water level has dropped the
evaporation by a hundred milliliters to
about two thousand and fifty milliliters
the water column has become clearer but
still contains clay in suspension note
the dark particle of organic matter just
to the right of the 500 milliliter mark
this is sitting on top of the clay layer
how did this get there just after
stirring would stop this particle of
organic matter was floating on the
surface with all the foam it remained
there for a few days but when it became
waterlogged it sank and because of its
position was deposited after the very
first of the thin layer of clay the next
image shows that the water level is now
down to 1,000 800 milliliters another
week has gone by the water column has
become clearer and a hill of sediment
hiring the setter and less thick at the
edges is discernible through the haze
some clay is still in suspension in this
image the water level has now fallen to
one thousand four hundred and fifty
milliliters another week has elapsed the
hill of sediment at the bottom can be
clearly seen now and the water column
has become clearer but still some of the
finest clay remains in suspension after
another week the water level has dropped
to just under 1000 milliliters prior
stands or levels of water are clearly
evident on the side of the beaker as
thin lines of draw
I sediment two weeks later the water
level has fallen to about 700
milliliters this image was taken from
above looking down on the sediment hill
the hill is barely covered with water
and is ready to be exposed a few days
later the hill is just exposed the
shoreline can be seen circling the
volcano like Hill this image was taken
at the same time as the previous image
but from the side some water still
remains the next image shows that all
the water has evaporated and mud cracks
have begun to form in the drying clay
the mud cracks at the top have begun to
pull back and curl away from the top of
the hill in this image the mud cracks
have fully formed producing a dramatic
volcano like structure they have curled
back from the top of the hill exposing
the sand underneath the mud cracks
themselves can be seen to consist of a
thin layer of clay and then silt and
then sand attached at the bottom